i heard the pastor distinctly say
that the devil has a right to tempt us i
had never heard that before
please explain this
in messages to young people page 51
paragraph one ellen white writes
fallen man is satan's lawful captive
let me say it more embarrassingly
a willful sinner legally belongs to the
devil
let me explain a little further why did
jesus die
because of sin what is sin transgression
of the law
because the law was transgressed you
have law you have legal
something legal had to be done to
satisfy the claims of the law
death the death of jesus
was a satisfaction of the claims of the
lord the soul that sinneth
it shall die and so jesus died if he had
not died
no one could have been rescued from the
devil
sin makes us the devil's lawful captives
when jesus said in luke 19 10 the son of
man
is come to seek and to save save you
from what
and save you from whom save you from the
enemy
so fallen man is satan's
lawful captive the lord cannot prevent
the devil from tempting us all the time
he has to allow him access that we might
be tested
the devil must be allowed access
he does not have to have control but he
must have
he had access to jesus
so god cannot stop the devil from
tempting us but what we must do
is avoid unnecessary temptation by going
unto the devil's ground
we avoid that if we have to encounter
him let him come to us
let's not go to him